[Music]
what is the purpose of science it is to
create a view of reality it is to create
a stable view of realities understand
why things happen in the world a view
that kind of transcends the everyday
vagaries of life the Sun will rise the
rain will fall I mean did the ball will
travel in an arc at least in physics
that these are the things that occur
despite all the other noise and and and
joy and vagaries of living in the world
the experience that we have there's some
rock-solid kind of route to what's going
on in the world and we expect physicists
to find that so we usually think of the
theoretical scientist the theoretician
sitting working hidden paper blackboard
today a computer mathematic or a MATLAB
and they produce equations and they
change the world by the power of their
individual thought but science is a
deeply collaborative enterprise and I've
always been struck when I see physicist
in action how much they are teaching one
another there at blackboards explaining
an idea to a colleague then I see them
another blackboard an hour later
explaining the very same idea to a
different colleague in different ways
then they give a presentation then they
write a draft of a paper this is a
social enterprise and they kind of go
back and forth between the individual
sitting struggling against you know the
brick wall banging their head against to
trying to make sense of reality and the
collaborative social side of things so
one thing that's crucial to that is that
all scientists have to gather around
them some kind of friend rube so science
probably more than a lot of jobs really
depends on strong personal friendships
among people and one reason for that is
a it just makes things a lot more fun
that you work with people that you
admire and that who admire you but also
just as a practical mechanistic level
these are the first line of people that
you can try ideas out on and they won't
say god that's a dumbest idea I've ever
heard they're gonna say
sure about that idea they're they're
more sympathetic to you you feel easier
broaching ill-formed or dumb or just
incomplete ideas with them before kind
of propagates out into what could be a
very vicious marketplace of ideas and
very unforgiving one that is beyond
those immediate circle of people
sometimes the idea isn't located in
either person's head but it's kind of
floating in the space between them and
each person is kind of contributing to
it in the ideas growing and growing or
growing Einstein for one loved it he
reveled in this kind of intellectual
play so he had a series of very famous
encounters with Niels Bohr at a series
of meetings in the 20s and well really
in the twenties and the thirties things
kind of all fell apart and for Europe in
general but certainly for the German
science community so in the 20s and the
teens he went to these conferences and
would encounter these other scientists
who just didn't accept what he was
saying and they would go off and usually
off the record and these have had to be
reconstructed by historians had these
intense debates over breakfast over wine
over just walking down the street
Einstein would engage in these kinds of
intellectual games really with Niels
Bohr and the other scientists and there
were some famous episodes were on Stein
for instance tried to question the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and he
would come up with a ha here's a way to
get around the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and that Niels Devore would
stay up all night and come back the next
day and say well no that won't work
ah here's another one said Einstein I'm
yield for ever go back and figure out a
way it didn't work and they would go
back and forth and what's funny about
this and in a way is that Einstein
really never really doubted the
uncertainty principle he accepted it he
accepted it kind of at least maybe not
from the very beginning but once the
mathematics was worked out he accepted
it and yet he kind of poked and prodded
at it because he thought such a strange
feature of reality that it's uncertain
it's in deterministic should have some
deeper meaning and he tried to pick poke
that principle and explore from
different sides to ascertain the meaning
so you need that kind of competitive
idea building and I wouldn't necessarily
call it adversarial because Niels Bohr
and Einstein considered themselves
considered one of their close close
friends when Bohr came to Princeton
Einstein gave Niels Bohr his office and
said he here you work in my office I'll
go sit in the assistants office I'll sit
where the Secretariat sits
I mean they were really close and Bohr
reciprocated that Bora thought very
highly of Einstein he considered him
friend as frustrated as Bohr sometimes
could get with Einsteins and ceaseless
questioning he loved it so businesses
start like every scientist is engaged in
an intense dialogue and interaction with
their their peers with their colleagues
and people further afield that does not
however mean they convinced each other
sometimes they don't or sometimes they
stake out positions and hold to those
positions and there's actually a very
interesting study done by sociologists I
think it was in the early 70s of
scientists involved in the Apollo
program dim the moon shots and they
actually did a lot of interviews and
surveys of the different scientists who
were studying the moon rocks and the
geology of the moon and one thing they
found is that the most creative
scientists were the most stubborn they
were the ones who were least likely to
change their opinion and reaction to
other people so you don't want people
falling too soon you don't want people
just like caving in right away people
should stand their ground and let the
idea sink or swim
rather than fail to give it to do that
it needs it's just amazing the kind of
intellectual play that physicists engage
in and that is essential to the progress
that they make
[Music]